bonjour denis jacob merci de répondre à
nos questions sur rt france les moyens
de la police sont ils si bas qu'il
faille faire un appel aux dons pour
avoir du matériel de protection de base
de quoi est-ce que vous avez besoin
concrètement et quelles sont les
quantités dont vous avez besoin
malheureusement les policiers nationaux
ne sont pas les seuls dans ce cas là je
voulais en parler sur votre antenne des
personnels soignants manque cruellement
de masques mais nous avons aussi nos
collègues gendarmes pompiers douanes
policiers municipaux enfin tous ceux qui
sont en deuxième ligne pour lutter
contre l'épidémie notamment en faisant
respecter les mesures de confinement et
les moyens matériel qui nous manque ce
sont ceux que nous demandons depuis
maintenant un mois puisque déjà le 26
février dernier j'alertais le ministère
de l'intérieur sur l'absence de moyens
de protection pour les policiers donc ce
sont des masques ce sont des gants ce
sont des gels hydroalcooliques tout ce
dont on a besoin pour se protéger quand
on contrôle des personnes parce que ces
personnes elles mêmes est porteur du
virus comme nous nous pouvons aussi être
vecteur du virus et qu'il est important
que nous protégions pour nous pour notre
travail pour de meilleures conditions
d'actions mais aussi pour protéger nos
familles votre appel aux dons a déjà
porté ses fruits dans plusieurs région
grand-est horizon encore rennes est ce
que c'est rassurant
ce qui est rassurant c'est la solidarité
la générosité qui se fait jour depuis
maintenant 15 jours nous avons eu plus
de 30 mille masques sur la région grand
est mais ça arrive aussi dans les autres
régions on vient d'obtenir 800 flacons
de gel hydroalcoolique par la société
l'oréal notamment dans le puy de dôme
nous avons eu six ans masc dans le 93
bref le système d s'organise puisque
pour le moment et le président de la
république a d'ailleurs réaffirmé ce
midi dans son intervention télévisée que
de toute façon ils ne pouvaient pas
promettre de pouvoir donner le matériel
nécessaire
aux autres agents de l'état en dehors du
personnel soignant
donc il nous devons nous organiser c'est
notamment pour cela qu'on a mis aussi en
lui une cagnotte donc sur notre site
internet alternatif bn.fr on est déjà
pratiquement en 2000 euros en cinq jours
et je ne désespère pas d'avoir beaucoup
plus afin de pouvoir acheter du matériel
en nombre mais pas uniquement pour les
policiers municipaux nous l'avons dit
dans notre communication plus nous
aurons participation plus nous pourrons
partager le matériel notamment aux
personnels soignants mais aussi à nos
autres collègues des autres ministères
qui sont engagés dans cette lutte contre
le coronavirus rené jacobs vous venez de
parler de l'intervention à la mi journée
d' emmanuel macron le chef de l'état a
fait des annonces donc en termes de
production de masques il a également
qualifié jeudi d'irresponsables ceux qui
cherchent déjà à faire des procès votre
réaction
moi je ne suis pas là pour faire des
procès nous constatons juste que nous
avons alerté au niveau du ministère de
l'intérieur depuis plus d'un mois que
mieux vaut tard que jamais je dirais
mais on regrette malgré les signaux
d'alert nous n'ayons pas eu une réaction
plus rapide en tous les cas au sein du
ministère de l'intérieur pour prendre en
compte les preuves les problématiques
qui nous était remonté puisque le 26
février à l'occasion d'un comité
ministériel
j'avais fait part de la situation à la
frontière italienne où on savait qu'il y
avait déjà la pandémie et où nos
collègues demandé des moyens de
protection et à l'époque on nous avait
dit qu'on faisait une surinterprétation
de la situation c'est regrettable
aujourd'hui au vu de cette situation
mais il est clair que sans faire de
procès d'intention
je pense et je l' ai déjà demandé dans
une comète dans une communication donc
je la prends à personne mais mon
organisation syndicale est la première à
dire qu'il faudra effectivement qu'il y
ait une commission parlementaire à
l'issue de cette épidémie pour voir les
dysfonctionnements qui ont pu avoir lieu
s'il y en a eu et puis en tirer toutes
les leçons pour que ça ne se reproduise
plus à l'avenir
le but n'est pas de critiquer mais d'en
tirer des leçons et de mieux s'organiser
à l'avenir c'est ce que je pense a fait
le président de la république dans ces
annonces ce midi mais de parler de votre
syndicat ya également un autre
syndicat de police alliance qui parle de
dix mille policiers à l'arrêt pour
suspicion de contamination 257 agents
seraient infectées selon ce même
syndicat est ce qu il ne va pas y avoir
de moins en moins de fonctionnaires
disponibles alors déjà il faut rectifier
ses 336 policiers qui sont porteurs du
virus aujourd'hui on a eu des chiffres
actualisés ce matin et on a moins de dix
mille agents confiné confiné ça ne veut
pas dire malade ça ne veut pas dire
porteur du virus c'est potentiellement
des policiers qui ont été en contact
direct avec une personne porteuse du
virus ça ne veut pas dire qu'ils en sont
porteurs mais la 14è nous oblige aussi à
nous confiner pour être sûr de ne pas
déclarer la maladie donc oui on a on est
à près de dix mille agents qui sont
confinés
pour autant nous sommes cent cinquante
mille agents au ministère de l'intérieur
police et des gens de police pardon et
donc les effectifs sont présents et puis
il y à une organisation interne qui a
été mis en place ce qu'on appelle le
mode dégradé pour permettre à ce qu'il y
ait un turn over et un effectif
suffisant tous les jours dans n'importe
quels créneaux horaires sur le terrain
un dernier mot dernier jacob sur l'état
d'esprit des policiers qui ont été très
largement sollicités ces derniers mois
dans quel état d'esprit sont les
policiers l'état d'esprit c'est entre
mécontentement et inquiétude
mécontentement parce que effectivement
au vu de toutes les annonces
gouvernementales qu'on a eu et bien le
matériel se fait toujours attendre
et puis de l'inquiétude parce que ils ne
sont pas à l'abri de contracter le virus
faute de moyens de protection et surtout
leur famille mais pour autant je
rappelle que nous avons toujours été
présents sur le terrain et
malheureusement depuis les attentats de
2015 on a eu d'autres événements
importants dans notre pays
nous avons toujours fait face nous avons
toujours fait front nous sommes des
professionnels de la sécurité
nous avons été formés pour ça nous
sommes rentrés dans la police pour
servir l'état pour servir sur tous nos
concitoyens et face à cette pandémie
nous continuerons b c'est vrai qu' il
est temps de donner tous les moyens
nécessaires de protection sanitaire pour
qu'on puisse travailler dans des
conditions optimales de sécurité et
c'est pour cela que nous mettons en
place un système d d'organisation
d'appel à génos risée générosité la
solidarité bas parce que je me répète
les moyens institutionnels de protection
se font toujours attendre
merci à denis jacob d'avoir répondu à la
question je rappelle que vous êtes
secrétaire général du syndicat
alternatif police cfdt